[Music]
recently the Academy announced the new
category devoted to popular movies the
decision was met with immediate backlash
why exile popular movies to this
separate category
why isn't Black Panther worthy of Best
Picture in reality this was likely done
as a way to boost ratings of future
shows
there's no reason there can't be a new
Oscar category in fact we can think of
several that would make more sense the
stunt community has been trying to
secure a category at the Oscars for
years only to repeatedly find themselves
out in the cold I've heard every single
decision as to why they don't want us in
there but none of them make any sense
and the public wants to send there our
peers want us in there the truth of the
matter is stunt coordinators are an
incredibly valuable part of any
production you might not notice it but
without their work some of the most
memorable action scenes would not be
done both smoothly and safely plus if
the Academy really wanted to honor some
of Hollywood's most popular movies this
would be a perfect category for it
[Music]
motion capture is a process in which an
actor's movements are recorded and used
to create a character digitally bringing
out a performance while wearing this
type of suit isn't easy and it's not
done by CGI alone Andy Serkis who played
Gollum in the Lord of the Rings and
Caesar in the new plan of the ape series
is a mocap pioneer Josh Brolin also
brought unexpected level of depth to
Thanos in Avengers infinity war while
wearing a mocap suit either the Academy
should start taking these performances
more seriously or give them their own
slot
in addition any actor who works
alongside someone in a mocap suit and
keeps a serious face should probably win
some kind of award the stereotype goes
that when an actor gets cast in an
animated movie they get paid millions to
simply record their voice while wearing
pajamas not true just look at how much
the rock put into his performance as
Maui in Moana
[Music]
Hollywood has never fallen out of love
with big musical numbers if you look
through oscar history you'll see
musicals everywhere you look
[Music]
chances are the likes of la-la-land and
mamma mía
here we go again wouldn't have been such
big hits without the choreographers
behind the scenes helping to make every
dance move happen musical numbers
deserve as much respect as any major
fight scene
[Music]
even the Emmys give out an award for
outstanding casting casting directors
play a large role in finding actors for
a given production
take for example Nina gold who has
worked on the new Star Wars movies she
is the reason that John boyega and Daisy
Ridley are now household names do you
really want to see a movie chances are
that's because of its trailer if you
think about it putting together a movie
trailers like putting together a movie
every trailer has a whole crew behind it
editors and a story arc to follow movie
trailers can help build up excitement
for movies you might not have been
thinking much about in the first place
and getting you even more hype for
movies you already couldn't wait for
there's a lot more that goes on behind
the scenes of a given movie than we can
ever imagine it's time to let the world
know a little more about it
[Music]